[Music]
it's time for et's social studies what
stars are posting online yeah they love
it
kendall Jenner poses in lacy lingerie
for a new photo shoot with love magazine
the 21 year old model flaunted her slim
figure in a sheer bralette and panties
and gave us old Hollywood glam vibes
with her 1950s inspired hair and makeup
kendall also instagrammed another racy
pic on the hood of a dusty car that read
boys life moving on KOCO Austin shares a
risque throwback photo from her modeling
days the 37 year old posted this pic on
social media posing on an exotic car for
a calendar shoot
she shot nearly a decade ago Coco had
her curves on full display in a string
bikini and captioned the pic not sure if
I have the same confidence I guess I
feel sexy in a different way now hashtag
the diva and leave it to Mariah Carey to
work out in a sexy ensemble the pop diva
instagrammed a series of gym pics
wearing fishnets and stilettos from
Rihanna's Puma collection here's Mimi
showing off her toned legs and booty
while leaning on a Stairmaster machine
RiRi reposes the pig caption I made it
[Music]
you